Good afternoon,
everybody. My name is
Dr. Richard Morgan,
and I'll be presenting
the lecture
today for DPR on
musculoskeletal of the
wrist and the hand.
Today's session
objectives, the student
physician will be able
to demonstrate the
components of the
history and physical exam
of the wrist and the
hand, to evaluate the
patient utilizing
inspection, palpation,
active and passive
range of motion,
as well as motor
strength testing,
neurologic, vascular,
and the osteopathic
examination on the
wrist and the hand.
Third, we'll be
applying the testing
and signs of the
wrist, including
the special tests
of Phelan's test,
Tenelle's sign,
thumb abduction,
the Allen test, as well
as the Finkelstein test.
Four, we will also
be discussing and
distinguishing normal versus
abnormal exam findings
to discern the difference
between the two.
Five, anticipate and
discuss different
common abnormal
exam findings,
including carpal
tunnel syndrome,
scaphoid fracture, as
well as the Quervain's
tenosinomitis and
osteo and rheumatoid
arthritis. And then
finally, we'll recall
an appropriate way
to document common
normal and abnormal
findings of the history
exam by writing a
SOAP note with the
case that I'll be
providing within the set
nine minutes that we
normally like to do.
So what are we going to
be talking about today?
Well, we're going
to be discussing
the history
considerations for
musculoskeletal
complaints, focusing on
the wrist and the
hand. Now, it's not
that much different
than any other
musculoskeletal
examination that you'd be
doing from the standpoint
that you're going
to be trying to
identify exactly what's
going on in that
particular area. We're
going to be examining
a full physical exam
of the wrist and the
hand, also be testing
for abnormalities
of the wrist and the
hand, and then finally
we'll be doing some
osteopathic treatments
as well as some
soaked up writing as I
previously mentioned.
What are some of the
pearls here? As with
anything, the mystery
is going to be in the
history. Taking a
detailed history will most
often more than not give
you much more insight
and really give you
some leads as to what
the differential
and what likely the
diagnosis will be. So it
really is important to
get a really detailed
history of present
illness that will really
help you focus your
physical exam on the
pertinent areas necessary
to come up with your
specific diagnosis.
Second, we need to get
quizzical with your
physical. Why am I
doing this? What test am
I going to do to
include or exclude my
diagnosis? Is there a
more specific exam that
I can perform that
will really hone in on
that diagnosis? Because
we have some very
sensitive and as well
as specific exams that
we can perform to really
isolate and determine
the ideal and exact
cause of what the
chief complaint might
be from the patient.
Now, here's just an
overview, a musculoskeletal
overview or an
algorithm, if you will,
on a typical musculoskeletal
complaint from
the wrist. And we don't
have to go over it in
detail, but it's
really laid out for you
here, really just to
give you an idea of the
types of questions and
things you're going to
be focusing on. Now,
once you make the
determination on whether
it's acute or chronic,
is it articular pain
versus a muscular pain?
By trying to isolate
and determine the length
of time the patient's
had it, the location
of the pain and the
symptoms included
will really help you
to follow this sort of
algorithm and give you
a very specific idea
as to what the diagnosis
will likely be.
So keep those
things in mind
as you're moving forward.
now wrist in hand
history what is the most
important thing we need
to do first once the
patient comes in with
their chief complaint
we need to determine
the mechanism of injury
and what's the best
way to do that and
like i always say in
dpr you need to ask the
patient one simple
question what were they
doing at the time that
the pain began maybe
it was subtle maybe it
was chronic maybe it
was something that was
insidious and happened
over a long period
of time. But a lot of
times you can really
get a lot of insight as
to what was going on
when they say that
their pain began. Did
they fall? Did they wake
up with the pain?
Has the pain kind of
slowly and steadily
progressed without any
particular specific
onset over the course of
many weeks or months?
So really understanding
the mechanism of injury
of this wrist and
hand situation will
really give some really
solid insight as to
finding out what and
determining what the
diagnosis is going to be.
Wrist and hand history,
right? So now we have
what? The location.
Where is the pain? Okay.
What's the best way
to determine where the
pain is? Have the
patient point to it. You
know, we're talking
about a lot of small
bones in the wrist, right?
We have eight carpal
bones. We have multiple
proximal and distal
phalanges. We have the
radius and ulnar and
other bones as well.
So we really need to
have the patient take
with one finger, maybe
just point to the location.
Where does it hurt
the most? That can give
us a lot of insight
just by doing something
as simple as that.
And that would go with
any joints as well.
Is the pain unilateral
or bilateral?
Is it in both risks
or one? Did it begin
simultaneously in
both risks or did it
begin in one and get
worse in the other?
So really having
an idea as to where
the pain is and if
it's symmetrical
will give us more
insight as well.
As with our OPPQRSTA,
we ask about pain
grading. On a scale
of 0 to 10, 10 being
the worst, how
severe is the pain?
Does the pain progress
throughout the day?
Has the pain progressed
over the course
of the chief complaint
for this last
hours, weeks, months,
for however long
they've had the
pain? Has it been
consistently bad or has
it been progressing?
And these are very
important because
it goes to the
severity of the injury.
For instance, a patient
with carpal tunnel
syndrome, the pain can
be low to medium grade.
But a patient with a
compartment syndrome,
which is a much more
significant, potentially
dangerous injury,
the pain is you often
at a time's proportion
to the physical exam.
Does the pain
radiate? Does it stay
localized to that
particular bone, that
particular muscle,
that particular tendon?
Or is it traveling
from somewhere? Is
the pain coming from
outside the wrist?
All these things are
going to be important
in your history of
present illness.
Next, we need to talk
about swelling. Are
the wrists swollen?
Are the hands swollen?
Is it noticeable?
Does it go up and
down throughout the
day? Is it worse
when they're typing?
Is it worse when
they're doing
certain activities?
You know, getting
a timing on the
swelling is going
to be really, really
important as to
helping us determine
the ultimate diagnosis
in this case.
what was the onset of
this pain did it happen
immediately did they
fall on an outstretched
hand did they were
they writing for the
past are they typists
are they writing um
an essay are they
studying for a board exam
like some of you here
or was it insidious
was it something that
they really can't
pinpoint did it happen
many months ago and they
said you know what the
pain was there didn't
really notice it until
maybe the past few
weeks and then i was
like you know what i
had no but didn't
really pay attention to
it. So it really is
important to get a real
idea, a solid grip on
when the pain began.
Second, progression.
What's been going on
since the onset? Has the
pain been steady? Has
it had an upward slide
or a downward slope?
What has been going
on since the pain and
what have they been
doing to help it? Okay.
Parasthesias. Okay.
Are they experiencing
any numbness, tingling
in their fingers?
And is it specific
to a specific
dermatome or nervous
nerve root, right? And a
lot of times the pain
can have begun in
the shoulder. It can
begin in the neck.
So really having
an idea as to where
the numbness or tingling
is occurring and
what distribution
will give us an idea
as to the specific
area, muscle,
tendon, or nerve
root involved. And of
course, which fingers.
Which fingers helps
us determine the
nerve root as well.
Oftentimes, you'll hear
a patient say, well,
I just feel the pain in
the latter two digits,
okay, the pinky and
the ring finger. And
if they say that, that
gives you a little
bit more insight as to
where the pain might
be coming from. It
could be a neuropathy in
the wrist, and even more
commonly, it could be
a neuropathy at the
elbow, causing that sort
of numbus and tingling.
So it really is
important to get a real
solid idea as to not
just whether or not
paresthesias are present,
but which fingers and
digits are involved.
Was there any aggravating
activities the
patient is doing
that brings on this
pain? Are they typists?
Are they secretaries
or administrators?
Are they driving
a car all day? Are
they working out at
the gym and maybe
they hurt themselves
doing some strenuous
activities there?
Find out about their
activities of daily
living, what things
they do most commonly
during the day, and what
kind of things would
be aggravating that
particular pain. And
oftentimes they'll be
able to tell you, but
sometimes you need to
elicit it from them
and get a more detailed
history on that end.
Also very important
is understanding
whether or not there's
weakness involved. Are
the patients having
difficulty writing?
Something as simple
that we might take for
granted, turning a
doorknob. They can't
do a push-up. They'll
go to the gym and they
can't do a push-up,
or they can't type.
Now, why are these
things important? Well,
a lot of times you
might have someone who
might be an elderly
patient, and they may
live alone, and they're
independent, but
all of a sudden, if
they develop some sort
of risk dysfunction,
pain, weakness, it
prevents them from
being able to pick up a
spoon, pick up a fork
or a knife to eat,
you know, be able
to do any of their
activities of daily
living, such as bathing,
feeding, dressing.
This level of weakness
can oftentimes make
a significant impact
in the patient's
social history. So it
really is important
to understand how this
weakness is affecting
their daily life
because it really goes
to how you're going
to treat this patient
in the long run.
Unrepetitive
hobbies. The patient
likes sewing,
painting, archery,
****, even underwater
basket weaving.
And again, these are
things that patients
like to do and maybe
non-sequential when you
think about about it,
inconsequential when
you think about it. But
ultimately, what you
really want to do is
make a determination is
if these are things
that they like to do and
it's part of their
daily life and now they
can't do it, that is
significant enough to
make sure that you take
a very serious look
at this cause and treat
them appropriately
and really consider all
the factors involved.
Life lesson time.
After asking your
history questions, make
sure you have time to
think about what your
potential diagnosis
is going to look like.
You know, what kind
of things are you
thinking about? And I
always say in DPR, every
time you ask a question,
you really need
to start thinking
about why you're asking
that question. How is
this question going
to either include or
exclude the diagnosis
that I'm already thinking
of? Every question
you ask has a purpose,
and it's going to
lead you hopefully
towards the ideal goal
is to coming up with
the solitary singular
diagnosis, but over
times it takes a few
questions to get there.
And you really need
to ask each question
with the purpose in
mind is how this will
either include or
exclude something I'm
already thinking about.
How will this
list look after
you perform your
physical exam?
Like I say, most times
you're going to be
able to have a very
specific idea as to
what the problem is
just in your HPI, in
your history of present
illness. The physical
exam really helps
corroborate the
things you're already
thinking of, but that's
why the physical
exam is so important.
You really need to do
those detailed focus
exam based on the
results of the questions
the patient answered
and use those to either
include or exclude
your diagnosis, the
special test that we'll
be talking about, as
well as the motor and
neurosensory testing.
Second, what other
data will you need
from testing? Once
you determine that
there's a problem,
will you need to do
an x-ray? Maybe the
x-ray is negative,
but there's still
significant pain.
Maybe you'll
need to get a CAT
scan or an
ultrasound or a cyst.
Maybe you'll need
to do nerve testing
or an ENG,
electromyography, if the
patient is having
ongoing paresthesias
that aren't really
eliciting a possible
diagnosis, and
you need to really
localize exactly
where the
problem might
be. And all these
tests can certainly
help you out.
Again, if there's
neuropathies, and maybe
the patient's a
diabetic, you need to
get some blood work.
Let's see what their
A1C is. Let's check
the CBC and chem panels
to see if there's
something in there
that can really help
us, give us an idea as
to what the diagnosis
might be as well.
So these are all
things to keep in mind.
Now we're going
to be assessing
the four signs
of inflammation.
These signs are commonly
known as swelling,
warmth, redness, and
pain. Let's take the
first one. When we're
assessing swelling,
or two more, it's a
palpable swelling that
may involve something
like the synovial
membrane, that can feel
boggy or doughy. You
can have an effusion
across from excess
synovial fluid within
the joint space itself.
Third, you can have
soft tissue structures
such as bursa,
tendons, or even tendon
sheets involved. So not
only are we determining
whether or not
swelling is present,
but it's really important
to determine where
the swelling is coming
from. And by your
palpable capabilities
of determining the
type of swelling that's
present will tell
you likely the origin
of that swelling. If
it's from a membrane,
if it's from a joint
or fluid space, or
if it's from a bursa
that's burst or tendon,
or a tendon sheet
such as in the
cuervain's tenosynovitis.
Palpable bogginess
or doughiness of the
synovial membrane can
include something like
synovitis, which is
often accompanied by
an effusion. Palpable
joint fluid is also
present in effusion,
and tenderness over
the tendon sheets is
found in tendonitis.
second sign of the
four signs is warmth
or calor using the
backs of your fingers
to compare the
involved joint with its
unaffected contralateral
joint or with
nearby tissues if both
joints are involved
this increased warmth
can be seen in a
number of conditions
including arthritis
tendonitis bursitis as
well as an infection
of the bone itself
and osteomyelitis
so warmth is really
important too not always
seen but more commonly
seen in some of
the others so keep
that in mind as well.
The third sign
of inflammation
is redness or rubor.
This may not be as
common as some of
the others, but
redness over the
overlying skin,
although being the least
common sign of
inflammation, it can
also be seen in some
more superficial
joints like fingers,
toes, and knees.
So redness over the
joint can suggest
sometimes some other
forms of arthritis,
such as septic or
crystalline arthritis,
or even possibly
rheumatoid arthritis.
So it's really important
to keep this in
mind that if it is
present, it hopefully
will really isolate
particular diagnoses
that you might not have
thought originally,
and they can be
extremely painful,
all right? So that's your
third type of swelling,
of inflammation.
Finally, the fourth
sign of inflammation is
pain or tenderness,
or what we refer to in
Latin as dolor. Try to
identify the specific
anatomic structures that
are tender. As I said
before, when a
patient is telling you
they're experiencing pain
in the wrist or hand.
Excuse me. Have them
point specifically
to that area of
the hand that is
inflamed or painful.
That alone will
give you much
more of an idea as
to really narrow
down the diagnosis.
Diffuse tenderness
and warmth over a
thickened synovium
can suggest a form of
arthritis or
infection, or focal
tenderness can suggest
some injury or trauma
to a specific bone
or muscle. So there's
your four signs of
inflammation, and
all four can help
really elicit an
appropriate diagnosis
if done correctly.
Wrist and hand exam,
okay? How do we do our
exam? As we do in
DPR with most joints,
with most parts of our
anatomy, we start by
inspection. What are
we looking for? We're
looking for abnormalities
on inspection.
Are we looking for
cysts? We're looking for
trauma, lacerations,
abnormal joint asymmetry,
something that stands
out, but sometimes
some things that can
be more subtle. We're
often looking for
atrophy of a muscle,
which can also be common
in forms of neuropathy,
such as carpal
tunnel syndrome. And
I'll show you a picture
of that in a moment.
Palpation of the wrist
follows inspection.
When we want to
palpate, once we've
identified where the
likely source of pain
is, of course, we
don't want to start
there. We want to
start as distal or
furthest from that
point as possible and
work our way there
using our wrist and hand
landmarks that I'll
mention as well.
Once we've done
that, we move into
active range of
motion, meaning
active range,
meaning what the
patient can do
through the specific
various degrees
along a horizontal
plane to see if there's
any limitations.
Next, we're going to
do passive range of
motion, which us,
the examiner, will be
performing to see
if we can passively
move the hand through
those specific
barriers or if they're
limited due to pain,
swelling, or other
significant
possibilities.
Next, we're going to
do our motor strength
testing, okay? Like
we do with any joint
or any muscle, we're
going to be checking
the strength of these
muscles, zero to
five on a grade scale,
five being full motor
strength of that
joint, whether it be
flexion, extension,
radial ulnar deviation,
zero being no strength
present at all. And
just for completeness
sake, three over
five would be motor
strength, present just
against gravity. So
with those, keep in mind
that we really need
to do a specific motor
strength test exam
on patients with an
isolated and really
kind of a specific
diagnosis that will
really help elicit and
isolate which muscles
and bones are involved.
Next, we'll do some
abnormality confirmation
testing, some of the
special tests that
I mentioned before,
such as Phelan's test,
Tenelle's test, and
Finkelstein's test.
Next, we're going to
do a neurovascular
exam. We need to make
sure that the joint is
perfusing appropriately,
and that would
include something like
Allen's test, where we're
checking for vascular
compromise in the
wrist or in the hands,
as well as doing a
neurosensory exam using
pinprick and light
touch to determine if
there is a decreased
sensation in a specific
dermatome or nerve
root, which will also
help us confirm an
isolated diagnosis along
a nerve pathway. And
then finally, an osteopathic
exam and treatment,
which we'll get into
in a little bit.
Now, here's an example,
as I mentioned, of
thenar atrophy of the
hand and carpal tunnel.
Sometimes it can be
harder to see, but
in this case, you can
do a comparison and you
see the difference in
the left hand, which
is slightly atrophic,
but in the right
hand, you can see it's
very atrophic. And this
is usually a sign of
a more chronic case
of carpal tunnel. Once
this thenar muscle
has atrophied, it's
oftentimes due to later
chronic damage of that
median nerve through
the wrist. This is a
good example of that.
Here's an example of
inspection. Obviously,
this is a very
obvious dislocation of
the ring finger, but
just keep in mind,
things aren't always
this obvious. When you're
inspecting, you really
need to look for
sometimes subtle
changes or differences,
lacerations, bruising,
swelling, redness,
the things that I
mentioned earlier.
Keep those things
in mind as you're
doing an examination.
I'll give you
a few more examples
of that as well.
Here's an example of
a wrist, a left wrist,
and you can see here a
small lobular region.
This happens to be a
ganglion cyst. Now,
ganglion cysts which
sometimes can be
very obvious and visible,
like in this case,
but I can tell you on
firsthand experience,
I would see a lot of
these ganglion cysts
in my office. And a
lot of times if the
patient's wrist is just
extended or a neutral,
the size of the cyst
can often be masked
and actually disappear
completely as it's
hidden between the
muscles and tendons.
So in this case, if
one is suspicious of a
ganglion cyst, you
really need to have that
patient move this wrist
in a flex position
as this doctor is
doing, and that really
allows that cyst to kind
of, you can appreciate
it a lot more in
this position, and
it's pretty much more
obvious in this case.
Just to go over real
quick, here's just
to give you an idea
of the anatomy, the
bones in the wrist
and the hand, just
to give you an idea of
why it's so important
as far as location
goes. Like I said,
we're talking about
acarpal bones,
the radius of the ulnar,
multiple phalanges,
both proximal and
distal phalanges.
And really knowing
your anatomy and being
able to localize
where the pain is will
totally alter the
diagnosis that you're
going to ultimately
be treating and
assessing for. So
that's why it's so
important to really know
your anatomy in these
cases, and especially
your landmarks.
Let's talk about
palpation of the wrist. We
need to be able to
palpate key landmarks in
the wrist, concentrating
on any of the abnormal
areas that are noted
in the inspection.
As I said before,
when you're palpating
the wrist, don't
just start over the
area in question.
If there's pain,
let's say, in the
scaphoid region, make
sure you start as
far away as possible
and slowly move
towards that area.
First of all, it's going
to be uncomfortable
for the patient,
number one. But number
two, you might isolate
other specific areas
of involvement,
especially if it's a
synovial infection or
synovitis, or if there's
more of a generalized
inflammation in the
wrist causing other
structures to be
damaged. So keep that in
mind when you're doing
your palpatory exam.
And be systematic.
Don't simply jump
around because you can
easily miss important
things. Go in a
systematic fashion. If
you want to go proximal
to distal, distal
to proximal, as long
as you're consistent
and it helps you
ultimately come to
the proper diagnosis.
Now, here's a key
landmark, as you
can see, is the
scaphoid bone located
in the anatomic
***** box between
two of the tendons
of the thumb.
Very important here,
when you're examining
or palpating, as we
discussed in DPR, make
sure you palpate this
area, not with your
thumb. As we know,
the thumb contains an
artery that can
sometimes pulsate, and it
can mistake your
thumb or the patient's
thumb for your thumb
pulse. So make sure
you do not use your
thumb when you palpate.
But snuffbox tendons
can be extraordinarily
painful, especially
if there's a scaphoid
fracture, which is the
most common fracture in
the hand and the wrist.
So keep that in mind
when you're palpating.
And oftentimes, I've
had patients that I've
examined and palpated
the scaphoid bone,
and it's literally
painful before I even
get there. And I would
still consider that a
positive test. Again,
very, very important
to be cautious. Don't
just jump to it and make
sure that the patient's
ultimate level of
comfort is considered.
Another landmark is
the CMC joint at the
wrist, just at the
base of the thumb. Also
a common place of
insertions of various
tendons. Also a location
where you commonly
see forms of arthritis
as well. So keep
that in mind when
you're palpating that
area, as well as doing
a detailed history
that'll tell you if
there's any swelling,
any pain, any inflammation
at that joint.
Another local key
landmark is the hook
of the hamate,
located on the lateral
aspect at the proximal
point of the wrist.
You can see where this
physician is palpating
at that area. Again,
it can be very
tender to palpation if
there is any kind of
dislocation or fracture
at that point, or
possibly any other
tendinitis from any
other anatomical
structures that attach in
that region. So just
keep that in mind when
you're palpating
that area. But again,
it helps to isolate
and give you a specific
idea as to the diagnosis
in these cases.
another key landmark
are the mcp joints
at the dorsal aspect
of the wrist okay
also very common in
different forms of
synovitis arthritis
arthritis such as osteo
and rheumatoid
arthritis so these often
can be very tender in
those cases as well
and of course you
want to make sure you
check all of the mcp
joints and if there's
more than one
involved or if there's
only one involved
make sure you start as
far away from the
most tender involved
ones and then work
your way towards those.
Just another
example of palpating
the wrist, you're
working your way
more, in this case,
distal to proximal,
palpating specific
areas of that
wrist. You're
looking for swelling,
tenderness, any kind
of masses or nose
or nodules that might
not be present. We
showed you a picture
of a ganglion cyst,
and sometimes you
may not be that
obvious to see them,
and they could be much
more subtle. So
palpitating the wrist
in this way will
give you much better
insight as to
determining what's wrong.
Active range of motion,
what the first thing
we're going to have
the patient do is make
a fist. If there is
significant pain or
discomfort, they may
not be able to make a
full fist. Again, I
have them spread their
fingers fully out, okay?
These are just some
simple, easy ways
to really get a nice
comparison of
whether or not there's
any limitations
in their active
range of motion. And
please be sure to compare
both sides. You can
do them simultaneously
to get a very obvious
bilateral view, or
you can have them do
it one side at a time.
Either way is fine,
but I think that
sometimes if they're able
to, have them do it
simultaneously. Because
if you can visualize a
slight subtle difference,
you'll notice it much
easier when you're
doing it bilaterally
and simultaneously.
We're going to do
active range of motion
of the wrist and
have the patient move
along a horizontal
plane with their hand
in anatomic position,
have them deviate
radially at ulnar.
They should be able to
get about 20 degrees
to 30 degrees of
deviation either way, a
little bit less on the
radial aspect. But
you want to look to
see, this will help
discern what the range
of motion of the wrist
is actively. So keep
that in mind when
you're doing this. And
of course, it should
be done bilaterally.
Next, we're going
to do wrist flexion
and extension along
a horizontal plane,
bending at the wrist,
hyperextension and
flexing at the wrist.
You should get about
seven degrees of
extension with each. And
again, a significant
difference with either of
them can be easily
noticed if you're doing
them bilaterally at
the same time, or if
it's not possible, even
doing them one at a
time. And really note
the degree of extension
or flexion involvement,
especially if
there's a visible
difference. You really need
to note this in your
examination and in your
notes. It'll go a long
way towards really
understanding where the
patient's limitations
lie and how you might
need to treat it.
Now let's take a
little bit of a break.
I'm sure you're
all tired. Stretch
and shake out those
hands for that
carpal tunnel
syndrome that you're
feeling, and we'll
take a minute break.
Now that we've had
our break, let's
just move on to
the next section.
And here we go.
Now, as we assess
passive range of the
motion of the wrist,
again, this is what we
do to the patient.
We want to assess
whether or not the range
of motion is limited
just by pain or
possibly swelling as
well. There could be
a number of barriers
involved in that
range. So it's not only
important to assess
the range itself, but
what is limiting the
actual range itself.
And you need to do
this for any abnormal
joint found during the
active range of motion,
wrist, fingers,
digits, anywhere in the
involved joint, whether
it's bilateral or
unilateral, roll, keep
that in mind as well.
I mentioned motor
strength testing before,
we're grading it out
of a five. Just to
reiterate, five
over five is full
strength. Four over five
is slight diminished
strength, but still
against gravity.
Three over five is simply
movement against gravity.
Two over five is
where movement
or gravity is eliminated.
One over five is
slight involuntary
movements, And 0-5 is
literally no movements
at all. So keep
that grading system
in mind as you do
a detailed motor
strength testing of
each aspect of the
wrist and whatever
muscles are involved.
You also want to make
sure you assess grip
strength by testing
intrinsic hand muscles.
Simply have the
patient grasp your two
fingers. Have them
pull tight. You can
have them, I often have
them do it bilaterally
simultaneously,
and I can notice a
discernible subtle
difference sometimes between
the grip strength
on one hand versus
the other, especially
if there might be some
carpal tunnel, some
arthritis, some other
abnormality involved
in the squeezing.
Just keep in mind
that decreased
grip strength is
a positive for
weakness of the
finger flexors and
or intrinsic
muscles of the hand.
Grip weakness
plus wrist pain
can often be present in
Dequarevane's
tenosynovitis as well.
so just keep
that in mind.
Finger strength, if
there's any concern
with something
individually with each
finger, you should
test the digits, each
one, if there's an
injury to that digit,
whether it be a
trigger finger, a node
that's abnormal, or
just unusual pain
that's out of proportion
to the physical
exam, and use minimal
resistance. Let the
patient, it won't
require a lot of
resistance in order to
perform these tests.
And as always,
please make
sure you compare
both sides.
Again, resisted
range of motion
is also going
to be used here.
Again, in the horizontal
plane, assessing
wrist extension and
flexion, as well as
laterally, radial and
ulnar deviation, where
you apply a slight
resistance. And I set
up a video for you to
watch on one of the
next slides that you
can take four minutes
out of your way. It will
really nicely detail
the range of motion
motor strength testing,
as well as some of
the special tests.
Some of the abnormality
confirmation tests
that I mentioned before,
the first and most
commonly used will be
the Tenelle sign. It
essentially means to
tap over the median
nerve on the dorsum of
the wrist, right where
the median nerve
innervates into the hand.
By tapping on this
nerve at this location.
If it's positive, it'll
often reproduce pain
and paresthesias in
distribution of the
median nerve. Many
times you might do the
test and it may not be
paresthesias, it may
just be pain, and I
could still consider
that a positive test.
But keep in mind that
the presence of both
would indicate a likely
positive sign for
carpal tunnel syndrome.
open. And here's an
example of that Tinell's
test. Dorsum of
the wrist, apply a
slight tapping right at
the location, anatomic
location of where
the median nerve
enters the wrist. And
as you can see, it would
provide positive
symptoms. You simply
ask the patient, what
do you feel? And if
they say pain, you
could say where. If
there's anything else
besides pain, you can
ask them that. And
often times they will
say, I feel a little
bit of a tingling in
my fingers, usually
my middle two or three
fingers. So keep that
in mind about when
you're, how you're
asking the patient
what they're feeling
when you do the test.
Again, another
confirmation test would be
Phelan's test. This
helps us determine
whether or not there's
a compression of the
median nerve. What
we do is we hyperflex
both wrists and hold
the door, some of the
hands together for 30
to 60 seconds. We're
trying to assess by
compressing the median
nerve manually if
we can reproduce any
of the symptoms that
you normally see along
the lines of carpal
tunnel syndrome, which
basically mimics the
pain and paresthesias
of median nerve in
that distribution.
And here's an example
of how that would
look. And we will be
performing this in
DPR lab as well
and practicing this
with our fellow students
to see if you can
get or at least
assess for those pain
and paresthesias in
the distal fingers.
Next abnormality
test would
be Finkelstein's test.
And on Finkelstein's
test, what it does is
we're stressing the
EPB and the APL, the
extensor pollicis
brevis and the abductor
pollicis longus, and
trying to essentially
stretch out, put
stress on the tendon
involved in the
querivane's tenosynovitis.
So by having the
patient literally
tuck their thumb
in and having them
aim their thumb
towards the floor,
sometimes you can
facilitate them by
applying a little
bit more force.
Oftentimes, it's
very, very sensitive
that they have an
inflammation in the
synovial lining of
those two tendons, and
it'll be significantly
positive, okay?
And here's an example
of what that looks
like. They're applying
a downward force,
they're tucking their
thumb in, as you can
see, and they will feel
pain just along the
EPL and APB, right
along the wrist there.
Next is the thumb
ADduction test, where we
simply have them extend
the thumb, have the
patient abduct the thumb
against resistance.
If there is
weakness present,
it may indicate
carpal tunnel
syndrome. Can
anyone tell me why?
Well,
what it has to do with
is something I mentioned
before, the thenar
muscles involved in
this. And if there's
thenar atrophy, it's
going to have a hard
time being able to resist
abduction of the thumb.
Okay. So keep that
in mind with thenar
atrophy or other muscles
that might be atrophic,
oftentimes, especially
from chronic cases
of carpal tunnel
syndrome, this would be
a significant finding.
Next, in the event of
a serious injury, you
must always assess the
integrity of the nerves
and blood supply. It's
very, very important.
And an example of
this would be if you
have a patient that fell
on their outstretched
hand, and they have
significant, let's say,
***** box tenderness,
there's always a risk
of some necrosis of
the radial artery and a
vascular necrosis. So
it's really, really
important to keep that
in mind, as well as
damage to that bone. And
it can cause significant
neurologic compromise
and vascular compromise.
So really, if
there's any question,
whether it be due to
traumatic or other causes,
make sure you keep in
mind to really assess
the integrity of the
neurovascular supply.
What can you do to
do this? Obviously,
you can check the
radial artery, check
for a pulse on both
sides. Also, the
ulnar artery can be
checked, although
it often is times
too deep to palpate.
So we'll use the Allen
test, which I'll go
over in a minute, but
at least make an attempt
to do it. You may be
able to get it, but
if you're not, don't
fret, because we still
have the Allen test to
check. And again, pulses
are always graded on
a four-point scale.
Normal bounding pulses
will be two over
four, and that's
considered normal.
Now, like I said,
you may not feel the
ulnar artery, but one
way to assess Also
arterial supply,
if you're concerned
about loss of blood
supply, would be
capillary refill in
several of the digits.
So by compressing the
nail bed of a digit
for two to three seconds
and then releasing,
you should see almost
an immediate return
of circulation or pink
color to the fingertips
and the nail beds.
So keep that in time.
It really comes back
very, very quickly.
Normal time would
be anything less
than three seconds,
but oftentimes
you'll see it even
faster than that.
But again, it's good
to do it both sides so
you compare what a
normal and an abnormal
would look like. Usually
anything three to five
seconds or greater is
a positive finding.
Again, as I
mentioned before,
here's Allen's
test, which assesses
adequate perfusion
of the hands.
The way we do it is
we occlude both radial
and ulnar arteries.
We have the patient
make an open fist or
hand several times.
And what we do is
on the open hand, we
release the radial
artery and we look
for perfusion rapidly
back into the hand
against the hand
should be blanched when
you're compressing
it. And then upon
release of the radial
artery, it should
turn red within two
to three seconds or
sooner. It happens
very, very quickly.
Again, then you
repeat this for the
ulnar artery. And
once again, as always,
you perform this
test bilaterally.
It can also be done
before starting
an arterial
line to assess
perfusion of the
hand. So that's just
something else
to keep in mind.
So it's not just
something that we do for
a pathologic process.
It can be done to
assess when we're actually
doing a procedure.
Now, what about the
neurovascular exam?
As I mentioned
before, we want to
assess light, touch,
and sensation in
multiple regions of
the hand and wrist
to assess dermatomal
distribution of
the problem that
might be going on.
If there's a reduction
in sensation,
C678, wherever it
might be, by doing a
checking light touch
and an even sharp
sensation, this will
give us insight as
to where the
distribution is lacking.
So for light touch,
you can use a cotton
swab. For sharp
sensation, we can break
in half a tongue
depressor and use that
something as a sharp
tool and compare and
contrast both hands,
both digits, all
five digits in the
dermatomal distribution
to see where there
might be lacking
sensation, either
pinprick or light touch.
As I mentioned
before, this will be
a sample video.
It's about four
minutes long of
the wrist and hand.
I recommend everyone
should watch this at
this time. So pause
it, pause this video
and watch this and
you'll get a good insight
as to what a proper
physical exam includes,
including the special
tests as well.
Here's an
example of a case
that I've put up for you.
We have a 46-year-old
female who presents
with right wrist pain.
The pain started 10
days ago gradually
and has progressively
worsened. The pain is a
tingling numbness sensation
in the middle of her
palm. The pain rated
4 over 10 currently,
7 at its worst, 7
over 10 at its worst,
3 over 10 at its best.
She's tried hand
stretches, ice,
heat, 200 milligrams,
ibuprofen daily
without significant
improvement.
Typing at work makes
her pain worse.
She denies radiation
of the pain.
so what are you
thinking about
what's on your
differential i
want you to start
to put together
your thought process
just based on
the history of
presidentals what
could be going on
in this case on
physical exam she's
alert oriented to person
place and time and
no acute distress and
well groomed her
musculoskeletal exam
reveals on inspection
no gross abnormalities
There is some 10
minutes localized
to the midline of
her right wrist.
Her range of
motion in the non
-affected digits
shows full passive
and active
range of motion.
Tendons or non
-affected digits
glide freely
without evidence of
lag or incompetence
or triggering.
Neurovascularly,
she has symmetric
pulses and
sensation bilateral.
She does have a
slight decreased
grip strength of
the right hand.
On provocation tests,
she has a positive
tenel and positive
phalanx on the right side.
osteopathically she has a
decreased motion
to the lunate
capitate bones
of the right hand
so what do we do now we
need to consider
osteopathic exam
and treatment of
this patient okay
here are just some of
the techniques these
are things that you
should have learned
in OMM I'll just
briefly mention them in
the first slide
we're talking about a
myofascial wrist
retinaculum release, which
involves the physician
placing his fourth or
fifth digits of both
hands between the
patient's fourth and
fifth digits, and first
and second digits of
the palmar surface,
okay? The second
picture shows
dorsiflexion of
the patient's
wrist, which
is introduced,
and the physician's
thumbs overlie the
lateral and medial
attachments of the
wrist flexor retinaculum.
And then finally,
in the third slide
down at the bottom,
transverse distraction
is also applied to
the retinaculum by
using three-point or
four-point bending
techniques with a two
-point ventral and one
to two points dorsal
until relaxation of
the soft tissue or
release of the
restriction as obtained.
These are some
of the techniques
that you have
learned and will be
continuing to learn
in your OMM labs.
Here are some examples
of carpal bone HVLA.
In slide A, the
physician hands grasp
the patient's hand
and wrist. B, the
physician's index
fingers grasp the
anterior aspect of
the carpal bones.
In the third slide, a
dorsiflexion barrier
is engaged, and the
physician applies a
mobilization with impulse
thrust, moving the
patient's wrist downward
towards the floor
in a whipping-like
motion. And then
finally, in the lower
right slide, a palmar
flexion barrier is
engaged, and the physician
applies a mobilization
with impulse thrust
by moving the
patient's wrist in the
opposite direction.
These will help alleviate
some of the problems
and usually give
the patient some
immediate relief. One of
the things I love about
these techniques is
what we do as osteopaths
is by not just
diagnosing the patient,
but providing some
osteopathic manipulative
treatment in
the office. We can
oftentimes relieve a
significant amount of
the pain that they're
feeling, and they'll
walk out feeling
so much better after.
So it's really good
to have these tools
in your armory when
you're applying this
and trying to help
these patients with
these significant and
often painful and
disabling conditions.
What this is is an
example of an objective
musculoskeletal exam
in detail. When you're
examining a patient,
like with carpal tunnel
syndrome or some other
pathologies as we
discussed before, a
really detailed range
of motion exam is
important here. It really
goes to isolate the
specific motions involved,
and not only does
it help us diagnose
the patient, but it
knows the type of
osteopathic treatment that
we're looking to do to
increase the movements
in the barriers that
are listed. So really
keep that in mind.
The neurologic testing
listed here reveals
dermatome C678, all
the normal limits,
reflexes moving the
normal limits, and
cardiovascular,
including neurovascular
assessments,
are also the pulses
being 2 plus bilaterally.
As I mentioned, the
special tests of
Tenel's was positive
as well as Phelan's.
An osteopathic
exam was done as
above, decreased
motion to lunate
and capitate of
the right hand.
All of these can
be found in Bates,
in your guide to
physical exam and
history taking,
Chapter 16, and some
of the pictures,
again, in Netters.
So please refer to
these as well as the
previous slides and
please do not forget to
watch that video that
I mentioned before that
gives a nice really
condensed but comprehensive
four plus minute exam
on range of motion,
motor strength testing,
how to position
the hand, as well as
performing some of these
special tests of the
wrist and the hand.
thank you so much
for participating and
listening to my lecture
today if you have
any questions at all on
any of the information
here or any
questions in general
about the wrist in
the hand please do not
hesitate to contact me
my email is rmorga04
at nyit.edu it's
been a pleasure and
thank you so much. I
look forward to speaking
with you and please
do not hesitate to
answer any questions
down the line. It's
been a pleasure and
thank you very much.